foreign
[Music]
from the studio who released Lord of the
Rings and still lost money that year and
a director who's been trying to get
animals on plane since his debut
comes a B-movie that delivers exactly
what it promises in the title Snakes on
a Plane snakes check plane check
in 2006 fans convinced new line Cinema
that Snakes on a Plane was gonna be a
Smash Hit cranking out early internet
memes launching blogs and turning their
suggestions into reshoots until it
finally came out and proved for the
first time that the online weirdo
audience may be smaller than it appears
crime Lord Eddie Kim has just one shot
to kill a key witness before he
testifies and he's not leaving anything
to chance smuggling a bomb onto his
plane and blowing it up to release a
bunch of snakes to release a bunch of
snakes because when you want to leave no
Witnesses you Wrangle 400 deadly snakes
from a third party in Los Angeles only
one guy could arrange this many illegal
snakes have those snakes shipped to
Honolulu rig their cage hatch with
explosives ship those snakes back to Los
Angeles bring on an inside man at the
airport to tip you off on which plane to
Target employ different guys to load the
actual cool snakes under the plane and
soaked the passengers legs with
pheromones hire another person to break
into the plane and open an access panel
ahead of time somebody rigged this
access panel door to stay open so the
snakes could get out all instead of just
shooting this off at the airport or just
spiking his Red Bull you know
you know the little snake thing is
insane
they're some of the deadliest creatures
on Earth they can attack without warning
and one has just been Unleashed thirty
thousand feet in the air a Samuel L
Jackson protagonist
come on
FBI agent Neville Flynn is a bad
I
if you're watching it on cable TV I have
had it with these monkey fighting snakes
on this Monday to Friday play he's here
to save the day the only way a Sam
Jackson protagonist knows how yelling we
have to put a barrier between us and the
snakes let's go everybody move forward
cautiously Eddie Kim will kill you what
was the first thing I said to you
and it's a good thing he does because
this co-star isn't bringing much to the
table how you feeling
yeah fine
you ready for this
congratulations Nathan Phillips you are
the Sam Worthington of jai Courtney's
Flint Flint hey they got they got a
snake guy on the phone
no an entire cabin's worth of hacky
stereotypes like fake share from
Clueless played by an actual fake share
from Clueless a germaphobic rapper who
seems a lot more relatable now after
kovid
being coughing on me it's disgusting up
in here Keenan the turtle of his
Entourage a couple on their honeymoon
kids traveling alone snooty Brit from
first class Herbie pilot old veteran who
dies one month short of retirement horny
teenagers salty nuns old women who speak
Jive and Kareem Abdul-Jabbar oh wait I
was thinking of airplane again can we
just watch airplane again and that as
much as anything else led to my drinking
problem
that's better so blast back to the
naughty Audis for a Creature Feature
that's pretty self-aware that's good
news snakes on crack but most of the
time feels like something Beavis and
Butthead would come up with on the couch
what if like the airplane toilet had to
sneak inside and when you went to Pierre
they're like video in the wiener oh yeah
yeah and then like this hot chick takes
her clothes off in there and like a
snake pops on him bites her in the Boop
yeah and then like a snake bites someone
on their butt that'd be cool
story The hateful Freight witness for
the prosecution the good flight Paris
Texas Hilton 3-6 Mafia Grizz and.com
what the
Elsa Pataki playing a new mom whose baby
is in extreme Danger on a plane part one
of two Tim Hawkins Cobra Commander and
snake vision goggles
okay look snakes in a plane is a perfect
title but just for fun
black snake float
reptile wins 10 points for Slytherin
Monty pythons flying serpents
you know I feel like this airplane was
about to crash no matter what and any
one of those slimy little pieces can
trip a circuit or a relay or hydraulic
and this bird goes down faster than a
tie hooker
I never wanted it to be an epic
voiceover guy in the first place I
wanted to be a lumberjack reach for the
sky boy I don't have to win we both just
have to lose oh and in case I don't see
you good afternoon good evening and good
night